so we already have some experience with
traditional fixed-rate mortgages but
i'll give a little bit of review before
we talk about a little variation or
maybe you could say a big variation on
it which is a balloon payment mortgage
so right over here what i have depicted
are the different payments you would
make on a 30-year fixed mortgage so this
one right over here is 30
a 30-year
fixed mortgage where you have a fixed
payment every month of 1400
and the loan amount is 300 000 so before
you make your first payment you owe the
bank 300 000.
300 000 and you keep making these
payments and we've seen in previous
videos is that your very first payment
you see in magenta here is mostly
interest 1000 of that 1432
dollars is interest then the next
payment well you've paid down the
principal a little bit not a lot
not a lot that maybe looks like it's
about 400 something dollars now your
next payment 999 dollars of it is
interested the next payment 997
are interest and you keep doing that for
all 360 payments remember 30 years times
12 months per year you're going to have
360 payments and as you get to the end
of your 30-year mortgage most of your
payment is principal so on the two
months before you've paid it off that
358th payment only 14 is interest then
the next one only almost i guess
nine or ten dollars is interest then
roughly five dollars is interest and
then you have paid off the entire loan
so you have a fixed payment you also
have a fixed interest rate i haven't
said what the interest rate is here for
for for this for this mortgage but then
you pay it off over 30 years there's a
30-year amortization
30-year amortization so it's also
30-year
amortization and the word amortization
means kind of spreading out spreading
out something so in this case you're
spreading out the payments over 30 years
now given that why am i
giving this as the preface to a balloon
loan
a balloon
payment
mortgage well in a balloon payment and
this was a little bit confusing to me
the first time i learned about it
the term is different than the
amortization so for example you could
have a 10-year term balloon payment loan
year
term
that still amortizes over 30 years so
what do i mean by that
well in this situation your payments
could be exactly the same but then after
10 years because it's a 10-year term you
have the loan for 10 years after 10
years the loan is done for so 10 years
is 120 months so this is the 10 years
right over here it's the first 120
months
after 10 years so you amortize it
remember this this payment schedule that
we set up is based on a 30-year
amortization just as if we were doing a
30-year fixed-rate mortgage but in the
balloon payment if you had a 10-year
term with a 30 year amortization the
payments are the same but after the 10
years on that at the end of the loan you
don't just make that 120th payment you
have to pay back whatever the principal
is whatever's left on the loan so we see
that after 10 years what's left on the
loan is 236 thousand dollars 300 and or
352 dollars so in a balloon payment
you pay the loan lasts for 10 years even
though the amortization the the rate at
which you're paying down the principal
you're paying down the loan is the same
as for whatever the amortization
schedule is the 30-year amortization so
question is is well why does this thing
why why does this thing exist
well in some ways this this is like we
talked about in the adjustable rate
mortgages it's spreading the interest
rate risk between the bank and the
lender in a 30-year fixed loan all of
the interest rate risk goes to the bank
while in a adjustable rate mortgage all
of the interest rate risk goes to the
goes to the borrower here the bank only
is guaranteed to only take on interest
rate risk for 10 years then after that
they get the balance of the loan and
well and so you might say well what does
the borrower do or why would a borrower
ever want to do this
well they might want to do this because
maybe they get a slightly lower interest
rate than with a 30-year mortgage while
they get to have the exact same payments
and they get a lower interest rate
because the bank is taking on less
interest rate risk they have less risk
if interest rates were to spike up
20 years from now
and a lot of people might say well i
don't think i'm going to own this
property for more than 10 years so as
long as i get a 10-year fixed payment
then i'm you know at some point if i
sell the property in the ninth year well
then i just pay off i just pay off the
loan another possibility is that the
person thinks that they'll end up with a
lot of cash for some reason maybe
they're going to expect an inheritance
maybe they expect to earn more money or
another possibility if none of that
happens if after the 10th year they say
hey wait i still want to continue paying
this house down and i'm not i don't plan
on selling it and i haven't come up with
some windfall of cash to pay 236 000
then they can just take out another loan
to borrow the
236 000 and there's some risk involved
there because you have to feel good that
at that time you will still have a good
credit history you'll still have the
level of income necessary in order to
get another mortgage so hopefully this
gives you a sense of what a balloon
payment mortgage is it's not anywhere
near as typical as a
as a
a fixed rate 30-year fixed or 15-year
fixed or 10-year fix or as an adjustable
or as common as an adjustable arm or a
hybrid arm but they do exist so it's
interesting to know about them